congratulations on completing the course
we've covered lots of material in this
course and there's lots more we couldn't
get to mobile web development is a huge
topic and you're probably wondering
where to go from here now that you
understand the basic concepts you
probably have questions about things
like scaffolding and getting started
which libraries to use and how to deploy
your applications how to really
incorporate this knowledge into your
day-to-day work to learn more you can
visit html5 rocks follow chrome
developers on Google+ and check out the
chrome channel on Google developers live
for more information on dev tools there
are many handy tools out there that can
further streamline your development
workflow yeoman and grunt for example
allow you to scaffold and easily build
your projects